let's try to think about what eight plus
seven
is equal to and we can imagine that this
is like taking eight tomatoes and adding
seven blueberries and then saying how
many pieces of fruit do you have in
total
and i encourage you to pause the video
and try this out on your own
so i'm assuming you've given a try
so let's let's let's think about it a
little bit and the way i'm going to
think about it is i'm going to keep
adding tomatoes until i fill up my first
bucket of ten and then i'm going to see
how many more i have to add to get to
essentially add a total of seven
so let's
let's have one tomato
two
tomatoes three tomatoes
four tomatoes
five tomatoes
six tomatoes
seven
and
eight tomatoes now to those eight
tomatoes i'm going to add seven
blueberries
so that's going to be
one
two
and actually i'm gonna pause there
because i just finished a group of ten
this right over here i already i've only
added two of the blueberries i still
have some more blueberries to add but
just with adding those two blueberries i
have completed a group of ten
so i already have ten pieces of fruit so
i can represent that i know since i have
a group of ten here that i have one
group of ten so this is going to be a
two digit number where the digit on the
left is going to be a one but i'm not
done adding blueberries i've only added
two blueberries now let me add a third
three blueberries
four blueberries
five blueberries
six blueberries
and
seven blueberries
so i have a group of 10 and then above
and beyond filling out that group of 10
which is represented here because this
is going to be a two digit number this
is the left digit so this one since it's
in the tens place it literally
represents
group of 10 which is right over there
and then how many more do i have well i
have another i have another 5 ones
5 ones right over here
so we have one ten and we have five ones
so what is eight plus seven
it is
fifteen and another way just to remind
ourselves what 15 represents the 1 and
15 represents 1 10. let me write it down
it represents
it represents 1
and the 5 represents 5 ones
five
ones
and so another way of thinking about it
one ten is the same thing as ten
and five ones is the same thing
as
five so 8 plus 7 is 15 that was the
whole point of this video but we also
want to think about what these numbers
represent 15 literally represents 1 10
plus 5 ones or 10 plus 5.